We can find the distance from our broken down car to the town by setting up a
right triangle. We know the distance between the mile markers is 24, since we
can subtract the smaller mile marker from the larger one. So, this distance is
24 miles, and our north south distance here is only 7 miles. That was the
distance from the interstate to the town. We're looking for this distance d.
So, we'll have this leg squared plus this leg squared equals our hypotenuse
squared. Squaring the legs, we'll get 576 plus 49 equals d squared. This sum is
625, and then finally we will take the square root of both sides to solve for
d. We only need the positive root of 625 since we are dealing with distance, so
d is equal to 25. So, if you had to pick which town to walk to, it's actually
show to walk to town two. You have to walk 4 miles less than you would if you
walked all the way to town 1.